c'est maintenant
il
merci marianne james
ryan dunn bonsoir bonsoir écoutez on
vous connaissait surtout sous le nom de
hurricane gauche comme on connaissait
kad merad sous le nom de cad
il est ouvert à saint brieuc jo on vous
connaissez sûrement du brica fomula la
cantatrice hystérique de l'ultima
récital ce spectacle a été applaudie par
sept cent mille spectateurs depuis 1995
eh bien vous essayez n'y est pas c'est
fini wells et puis c'est fini voilà un
film pourquoi c'est fini je trouvais que
le public sacrément schizophrène et
louis en allemand les demandes en
mariage les ne pas pouvoir sortir sans
son petit radiateur portable ses
menottes alors c'est pas du tout ça
c'était un personnage alors le riz
qu'elle est finie mais vous revenez donc
sur celles en marianne james en concert
à la cigale les 29 et 30 mars pour le
caprices de marianne si bien trouvé il
ya huit chansons de vous donc qu'ils
sont un peu érotique un peu sensuelle un
peu sensuelle érotique engagé oui en
gris noir sont parfois moins par exemple
même quitte pas j'aurais bien aimé
l'écrire ça c'est franchement mais il
une que j'ai co écrite avec laurence
boccolini
ouais ouais juste copie avec laurence le
cueillir est très amis c'est quoi cette
chanson vous êtes avec laurence
s'appelle 3 14 116 le chiffre piquionne
à moi tous les jours là ce site a raté
un jour vise aussi des reprises d'oasis
de marilyn de nougaro c'est quoi la
reprise de nogaro vous faites mais
cinéma assez bien mais je le sentais
bien avant qu'il nous quitte
vous la connaissez par coeur la chanson
we all attention sur le derrière le jour
là
les grands noirs de mes nuits blanches
moi je me fais du cinéma sans pognon et
sans caméra
brad pitt que partir en vacances ma
vedette c'est toujours toi là pour te
dire que je t'aime
rien à faire je flanche
j'ai du coeur mais pas d'estomac
revanche sur l'écran noir de mes nuits
blanches où je me fais du cinéma
moi
ful
clever qu'il a créée en 1936 ah oui
1936 les mandarines voilà donc à la
cigale les 29 et 30 mars le caprices de
marianne et puis vous vous préparez un
spectacle avec quelqu'un que j'apprécie
beaucoup qui s'appelle thomas le douarec
qui s'appelle marianne 2037 c'est quoi
en fait revenir la république française
à marianne celle qui est là sans culotte
ouais mon et phrygien baïonnette drapeau
bleu-blanc-rouge pied nu aux seins nus
elle flotte elle sort avec elle la
guillotine aussi et on refait la
révolution et on décapite tous qui
travailla en démon pas endemol en deuil
d'accord voilà c'est pas une mauvaise
idée clef en plus oui il ya des clients
engagés
ça peut brûler les réservations se
booster les réservations c'est un style
mais ça peut vous serez alors il ya eu
beaucoup de rumeurs sur vous on a dit
que vous étiez un homme d'abord en fait
l'on est là qu il pense encore
franchement non on m'a pris pour un
garçon parce que les 10 les dimensions
du personnage j'ai presque deux mètres 7
2 au 1 m 67 de tour de poitrine et 2 mai
de 0,7 au tour à tour de manche à cause
de chaussures pas possible on se disait
c'est une femme peut pas être là dedans
première raison deuxième raison le
jargon vers verdru truculent presque
obscène parfois une femme ne parle pas
comme ça
donc après tout cette lutte de tant de
femmes j'ai appris qu'il y avait un
humour aux animaux bleus voilà ça c'est
la première rumeur à laquelle on vient
de tordre le cou on a vu que j'étais
anglaise alors que james est un
occitan non oui comment vous le savez ça
parce que je suis de là bas et alors
voilà le patronyme jammes veut dire le
jacques valeur tous les pèlerins qui
allaient vers la route de saint jacques
de compostelle
partout il s'arrêtait un quartier
saint-jacques été nommé mais en patois
occitan le jacques c'est le jeannois là
donc il y en a de montélimar à
montpellier en descendant sur saint
jacques de compostelle et enfin de
commencer les anglais qui nous ont piqué
ce nom on devrait dire jammes s'est
fondu dans cette télé genre de choses
qu'on apprend dans cette émission c'est
vrai c'est vraiment ça le service public
je crois finalement je le savais et
alors là aussi une rumeur qui a couru
c'est que vous posiez 10 kg à la
naissance
mersen quand vous pouvez alors justement
dernière mexique
et quand elle était petite
extraordinaire ça son père était
pâtissier nougatier à montélimar
bouffier rien rien la première action
avec la nourriture ça a été comme ça je
pense qu'ils ont vu la cuillère le 5 6 3
qui arrivait c'était comme ça doit laver
les amygdales figure toi elle avait des
énormes amygdales friis c'est vrai non
j'avais 3 4 engine paris vers
nourrissait pas et du jour on les a
enlevées dans mes cinq ans mon père m'a
fait que des glaces ce sera à l'époque
quand on se faisait opérer des amis dans
lé droit de l'ag que des glaces et que
vous souhaitez apprendre un truc banal
où les événements et aux missions de
service public
j'avais dit un truc qu'on apprend la
couture coup d'arrêt d'agen s'est aperçu
que manger c'était délicieux c'était
source de plaisir waouh voilà hier je
pensais pas aussi à votre sujet c'est
que donc une fois que vous avez pu les
amygdales vous êtes devenu bon jeu une
fois que j'ai pu devenir une femme
je pensais pas si vous avez appris la
guitare avec michel fritsch luciani
parce que le père de michel petrucciani
t votre voisin alors en fin de compte
tony petrucciani le papa de michel était
professeur de guitare j'ai appris à
l'âge de 11 ans j'ai commencé à 1 à ce
moment que c'est pas de la guitare avec
la famille petrucciani voilà et michel
et le même âge comment s'appelle comment
se construit la guitare si c'est ce qui
s'appelle la guitare et dé prendre pour
des cons
et ça c'est le côté boccolini et centre
au cameroun et buvez d'ondés dans des
verres on arrête arrête h on a découvert
assez rapidement dans la suite que vous
étiez une excellente vocaliste et que
simplement par mimétisme vous étiez
capable de reproduire trois octaves
ben c'est pas les reprenez vous savez
qu'il ya plein de gens qui ont trois
octaves
ah ben quand vous tapez un clown verso
sur les vols mexique vous pousser ces
trois octaves au moins enfin ces trois
octaves dans l'amour sûrement ces trois
octaves à sion devait prendre la hauteur
des notes des messieurs et défis je
pense que 3 octobre entre les premiers
seulement les premières caresses et les
grands cris à 30 secondes à faire voir
par exemple beaucoup de monde ça fait
attention et trois femmes et on est
parti je n'ai pas parce que je suis pas
connecté voilà si je les fais l'amour
juste avant de venir je n'ai rien eu
mais ça peut s'arranger tout de suite
que représente l'europe a fist présence
sort de prison et réceptive bien voir et
me dit bien alors y ait une autre
il ya une autre actu vous concernant ma
chère marianne
si vous faites partie du jury de la
nouvelle star sur m6 bon goût tiens donc
alors vous n'êtes pas armande altaï
avait dû réviser la prof de chant c'est
pas je suis pas censé être coach vocal
non alors on fait quoi quand on voit
arriver comme ça
pauvre mec ou une pauvre fille qui sait
pas chanter mais c'est ça va être
terrible je me mets à votre place dés
fois que je me dis mais qu'est ce qu'on
fait on rigole on pleure on gueule moi
j'en ris quand je sens que les gamins
vont pas se flinguer en sortant du
programme jeux gourmands de quand je
sens qu'il ya un vrai talon mais qu'il
ya une vraie fumisterie et que la
personne n'est pas en place - le gronde
parce que j'estime que du talent et qui
s'est gâché et on ne manque même pas
l'image que quand c'est carrément
misérable quoi mais les choses qui n'ont
pas été montée par qu'est ce qui n'a pas
été bien voilà qu'est ce qui n'a pas été
montré
oui sur la demande pressante du jury des
quatre il ya au moins quatre candidats
on a refusé de monter les images c'est
minable trop risible trop je crois
qu'ils allaient se bousiller la vie à
faire ça jean-michel à peu près
manuel et supplier d'être d'être pris
c'est vrai ça très bas en tout cas manu
katché était super percer le mystère ne
montre pas si on monte je décroche trois
oui voilà et les gens comprennent
facilement qu'on les vire non il y avait
beaucoup de souffrance beaucoup de
colère ils sont aigris c'est un peu
normal non vous avez pas peur de rater
un qui va devenir les normes 120
millions d'albums
c'est je pense que je pense qu'on a
peut-être loupé la nouvelle star oui ça
fait mal à repérer l édition c'était
deux fois ils attendent trois heures
dans le froid il est passé à 7 7 euros
et april tombe sur vous ou leur reste
encore à quai à 7 heures du matin pour
passer les premiers arrivent à 6 heures
du matin et on les auditions à 18 heures
donc il faisait froid ils ont quoi une
petite bouteille d'eau parce qu'ils ont
craqué le blé que pour le train ils ont
pas de sandwich et enfin la prod fait
pas saliver tout prévu il ya un trop
perçu c'est dur quoi ces endroits
combien de temps passez de oui ça peut
durer une minute
certains qui nous ont séduits ont eu la
chanson en entier d'autres
malheureusement quelques secondes ça qui
chante chaud cacao tous les soirs mais
vous aussi vous avez fait beaucoup de
galères d'audition oui énormément encore
aujourd'hui encore aujourd'hui je sors
d'une audition qui n'a pas marché
ça fait 29 safa 30 avec celle la rente
avec moi décembre une superbe audition
c'est une vengeance votre truc de nom
une requête est une vengeance pas la
nouvelle star est audrey cas où ils ont
pouvait plus que ce métier ne laisse pas
la place
et bien si vous voulez pas laisser une
place pour marianne ils font d'armand
donné deux pour des cas comme ça c'est
vraiment ça mais c'est terrible quand
même parce que moi quand je m'occupais
de graines de star je vais arriver des
filles qui chantait comme chimène badi
oui le producteur chimène badi lara
fabian céline dion ils sont tous sur le
même modèle la retrouver parce que
justement on les a pas gardé cela on a
pris des gens qui nous semblait
différent c'est difficile c'est le
terrible pour vous de voir arriver que
des céline dion au claj je voudrais dire
que c'est pas céline dion cette année ni
obispo qui ont été le plus chanté
c'était chimène badi et kyo et calogero
mais il ya des perles au milieu de tout
ça non des pères voulait dire des
réussit vraiment de la nasa
oui oui je d'histoire si vous avez
regardé le programme dans les dix et il
y en a quand même cinq qui sont des
véritables qui pourraient c'est pas des
candidats c'est pas des scolaires à des
artistes ils vont pas courir devant le
château sont et gazeux dit vrai derrière
un professeur privé ni faire des deux
des acrobaties et déportés en minijupe
ras la touffe il voulait dire oui c'est
pas la star a qui sont déjà très ils
sont déjà ça bien non mais ces derniers
l'ont ne même pas daigné encore le
nirvana lui et steve tu l'as vu ou pas
ça c'est impressionnant le wiki des
découvertes que ça moi maintenant on va
faire
on va faire une interview un petit peu
arroseur arrosé on va faire une
interview nouvelle star bonsoir vous
avez quel âge 49 ans il est lourd
montélimar ckoi monte lema une petite
ville dans la drôme spécialité de nougat
le nom gars comme ça voulait être la
nouvelle star alors je pense que je peux
devenir la nouvelle star
il faut quoi d'après vous pour faire une
star il faut pas couché faut avoir du
talent vous voulez casser en amateur
vous êtes prête à tout lâcher pour
réussir je suis prête à tout lâcher pour
réussir tout tout tout tout tout vous
croyez en vous oui
et inversement c'est pas compris mais si
vous avez de chanter quoi là l'intégrale
des oeuvres de wagner tombe bien vu
votre bois l'est pas pas encore très au
point vous savez ça ma voix elle et elle
est blanche j'aimerais qu'elle soit plus
noir mais nuance pas mal pour une
blanche il vous avez travaillé une
chorégraphié non je pense que pour être
une star n'a pas besoin de danser comme
un épileptique et vos cheveux vous allez
faire quoi vous êtes d'accord pour faire
une couleur ni maigrir niet blanc demi
avant les cheveux lisses tu vas aller
chez de toilette
c'est quelqu'un qui bouge pas c'est pas
moi
maria
si vous voulez être une star il faut
qu'on s'occupe un petit peu de votre
légende de la drogue vous en prenez
beaucoup mais je prends du nougat show
en goutte-à-goutte c'est un très bon à
la prostitution est donné le dos les
sens j'aiderai l'adolescence la position
à genoux me faisait terriblement mal aux
fesses d'accord l'enfant caché vous en
avez un j'ai trois enfants cachés mais
qui font le trottoir est aussi très bien
mais c'est bon pour la légende s'est
bien passé me dira je vous ai des vidéos
de vous un gogo danseur mois en gogo
danseur mais bien et comment j'ai fait
pour vous
ça leur roi